- [Sal] First civilization
that we have evidence of
around modern-day India and Pakistan
is the Indus Valley Civilization,
and it's right around the Indus River
in modern-day Pakistan
and northwest India.
In other videos we talk about how
it really comes into being
in the Third Millennium BCE,
and as we enter into the
Second Millennium BCE
it starts to decline.
We don't know exactly why it declined.
Might have been climate
change, drying up of a river.
Might have been a natural disaster.
It might have been an
influence of other peoples.
We're gonna talk about
in this video is the next
significant period in the
history of South Asia,
and it involves the
migration or the introduction
of another group of people,
we believe another group of people,
and that's the Indo-Aryans.
Write this down.
Indo-Aryans, sometimes
referred to as just the Aryans,
who we believe began to migrate
into modern-day Pakistan
and northwest India
at right about the same time that
the Indus Valley
Civilization was declining.
Some historians actually believe maybe
Indus Valley Civilization
declined because of them.
Maybe it was some type of an invasion.
Although that theory is
not as widely held anymore.
Some folks believe that the
Indus Valley Civilization
and this Indo-Aryan
migration somehow merged.
But this period that we're talking about,
with the migration of these Indo-Aryans,
this is called the Vedic
Period, or the Vedic Period.
It's called the Vedic Period because
we learn about it from a
collection of literary works
that we get from that time,
most famously the Vedas.
Veda comes from Sanskrit,
and Sanskrit is the language of the Vedas.
Vedas, in Sanskrit, means: knowledge.
And they're the foundation of, one,
what we know about the Vedic Period,
but they're also the foundation
of modern Indian culture and religion.
The primary pieces of the Vedas
are the Rigveda, the Yajurveda,
the Samaveda, and the Atharvaveda..
The Rigveda in particular is considered
the oldest of the Vedas.
It's believed that it was composed around
the early part of that Vedic Period,
between maybe 1500 BCE
and around 1200 BCE.
We're talking between
3,000 and 3500 years ago,
while these three Vedas we
believe were composed later.
Now, these Indo-Aryans, it's believed,
were essentially pastoralists;
they were cattle herders, perhaps nomadic.
But as they began to settle not
just the Indus River Valley,
they actually began to settle
the entire Gangetic Plain,
which would include this area,
which would be northeast India
as well as countries like Bangladesh.
The Indus and the Ganges are two
of the most significant rivers in India.
But as they started to
settle the Gangetic Plain
they also became more traditional farmers.
In this green here, I've highlighted
when they became more farmers,
and started to have more settled kingdoms,
or we believe started to
have more settled kingdoms.
Other significant Hindu epics,
we believe the events of the them
happened around that late Vedic Period.
The events of the
Mahabharata and the Ramayana.
Now, the Vedas and these epic poems
were originally orally transmitted.
But then, later, either
in the late Vedic Period
or after the Vedic Period
was when they were actually written down.
Just so you have some context here,
Sanskrit is considered one of the oldest
Indo-European languages we have.
I'll talk more about Indo-European
languages in a little bit.
Because it turns out
that Sanskrit is related
to European languages like Greek and Latin
and even Germanic languages.
Sanskrit's one of the oldest,
alongside Mycenaean Greek
and the Hittite Language.
Those were all contemporary civilizations
of around this period right over here,
in the Second Millennium BCE.
Just so have you context,
Siddhartha Gautama Buddha,
his life was in one of
these Vedic kingdoms
in the northeast of India.
Now, as I mentioned, the
Vedas laid the foundation
for much of what we consider
to be modern-day India.
In fact, the first documented reference
to the Indus River we have from the Vedas.
The Indus Valley Civilization,
we haven't been able to
decipher their writing.
They didn't write down the word Indus.
It was in the Vedas that
we have the word sindhu,
and sindhu was later
changed or mispronounced
or pronounced differently into other words
that we now associate with India.
Words like Hindu, Indus, and India,
they all derived from Sindhu,
which was the River
referred to in the Vedas,
and then changed into Hindu,
Indus, and things like India.
Now, also in the Vedas is the first time
that we have reference to a
stratified social structure,
and we see that with the
varnas that are referred to.
You could view these as
social roles or classes.
At the top you have the brahmins:
the priests, the scholars,
and the teachers.
Then the next you have
the kings and the warriors
referred to as the kshatriyas.
Then the vaishyas, who are the farmers,
the merchants, the artisans.
Then the shudras: the laborers.
Now, some historians and
Vedic scholars believe
that these reference to the varnas
were added after the Vedic Period
to things like the Rigveda;
and some believe that these
weren't traditional casts,
as it's sometimes perceived today,
but just a reference to
different social strata,
that it wasn't necessarily inherited.
We are not actually sure about that.
But just to give you a feel
of what was in the Rigveda.
I encourage you to go look
at the actual primary text,
and there's a lot out there to read.
It includes prayers; it
includes praise of the gods;
it includes rituals; but it also has
a lot of interesting philosophy.
And, for example, this
is from the Rigveda.
This is a hymn referred
to as Nasadiya Sukta,
and it's in the 10th book, the 129th hymn.
I find it really
interesting because it shows
a fairly mature philosophical attitude.
This is actually the origin hymn,
and this is just a part of it.
We're talking about the
origin of the universe.
"Who really knows?
"Who will here proclaim it?
"Whence was it produced?
"Whence is this creation?
"Gods came afterward, with
the creation of this universe.
"Who then knows whence it has arisen?
"Whether God's will created
it, or whether He was mute.
"Perhaps it formed itself,
or perhaps it did not.
"Only He who is the overseer
in highest heaven knows.
"Only He knows, or
perhaps He does not know."
I just find it interesting
because it takes a very
philosophical view towards
this very fundamental question
of the origin of the actual universe.
So the Vedic Period, very
important period in India.
It really lays the foundation
for what we consider
to be modern Hinduism, modern-day India.
It starts as really a
Bronze-Age civilization,
but as we get into the later Vedic Period,
we see them smelting iron,
and creating iron tools,
and things like that.
And, as we'll see in the next video,
the language of the Vedas, the Sanskrit,
when Western scholars
started to discover it,
it opened up their minds as to what were
the roots of many of
the peoples who settle
not just north India but also Europe.